but all I remember for the 90s is
various colored goose the stuff that you
got from infomercials is like you're
gonna just put it in a closet they're
things that you never knew you wanted
but they rope you in I just arrived from
the color workshop where I learned all
kinds of new tricks with the brand new
magic color change bullpens oh my god
Lopez this is a colored goo who kind of
intuitive I was always told not to sniff
markers or blow pain yeah you can't
inhale ink Wow let's see do you think
whoever this is like the precursor to
the vape oh my god I'm gonna pass out I
did it I'm Banksy I look like the
babadook making some progress let's
don't be dull be dazzling tassel with a
B Destler the kit that can change your
wardrobe from dull to daring it's a
bedazzler
it's for bedazzled in the original so
that means there's like a black market
that loves the dazzling I think even as
a kid I knew not to bedazzled one of
this came with like jean jackets is that
the only thing for the way it's like a
big stapler this is moving to play Mario
because we're making clothes
let's do you know what let's just do so
right like a stoplight I think this is
actually kind of nice you'll be the
belle of the ball with this bedazzled
Fedora this is pretty fun but also very
tedious about to be mesmerized it's here
it's wild it's sweeping the nation
it's Fushigi
haven't you seen the video where they're
like
Hey ladies do you like magic goddess of
magic and illusion maybe you decide I
can safely say that any kid that played
with this was the worst
I already feel very mystical in that I'm
like dr. scream did you have this Tori
look at ya four bad children who don't
deserve real toys
shape them wrap them stick them no glue
no stains no mess everything you make
with this just looks like it's fun it's
just spaghetti this is technically
colored do you think there's like a
secret underground community of people
who are into this this is what you make
and that's what like your cool artistic
babysitter makes these look delicious
let me give it a 6
well you know for six easy payments of
1099 those toys are pretty adequate
they're like that sign open but kind of
a letdown I think maybe that might have
been the key was like hands gave them to
these toys they realized they suddenly
you might as well do housework